One area where interactive 3D graphics is used extensively is in what's called
previsualization. That's where a director sets up a virtual world and sets his
cameras lights and so on. Doing this can cut cost and speed delivery. What
follows are some interviews with The Third Floor, a previsualization company.
[MUSIC] The third is a previz studio. We specialize in pre-production of all
types. working with different directors in both commercials video game
cinematics and feature films. The Third Floor originally was founded up at the
Sky Walker Ranch. We actually referred to the third floor of that building
where we were. Sequestered for a number of years on Star Wars episode three.t
At the end of our tour duty, we decided to get together and form our own studio
down here in Los Angeles. And Action. We made it a mission of ours to create a
room where we can have a virtual film making experience. Directors like to work
with a virtual camera. So we have a system that allows them to manipulate a
camera with a sensor on it. That's fed live into Motion Builder that actually
let's them manipulate around the Motion Builder camera. We have actually added a
Wacom tablet. And we use that as our viewer. And our input device for operating
a camera inside the virtual world. From there if we do integrate the motion
capture suit. We can record this information and they can actually create their
own shots. It really is an exploratory process that, that opens up the
directors to whole host of new possibilities.